there are some great scenes at ami
Aegon's conquest at the beginning of
this book as I would I be right in
saying you know a sort of you know a
version of the Norman conquest of
England of 1066 but on dragon back with
Dragon Age on the first arriving on
balerion the dread
I mean it is just amazing is this can I
ask one one of the HBO shows and
development can you tell us about any of
those by the way Blood Moon is wrapped
something hey I I can't go on
it's probably an HBO agent in there in
the auditorium even now I can say as I
have said before we we started out with
a number of different ideas all of them
prequels one show which I've been
calling the long night
what HBO keeps saying it's not titled
yet so the show that's not called the
long night yet has just finished filming
up in Belfast and is now and and other
places not just Belfast Italy as well
and Jane Goldman is the writer and the
showrunner on that you you've probably
been familiar with her work she was the
scriptwriter on several of the x-men
movies she did kick-ass and she did the
the Kingsmen of Kingsman things she she
scripted Neil Gaiman Stardust so she's
very experienced screenwriter and she's
done this story and it is set you know
five thousand years in the past of
Westeros so way way way before the
events of Game of Thrones and that
that's the one that is furthest along at
the moment and it's in pre-production
and right now it's just a pilot but it's
got Naomi Watts in it starring it's got
miranda Richardson a lot of other very
exciting actors and will probably be
finally added in the next couple months
whether HBO was actually gonna order for
the full series of that and meanwhile we
have two other pilots that are also in
active development at some stage and
hopefully in the near future one or both
of them will be a greenlit to shoot a
pilot and we may get more than one
Westeros show on air let's talk about
the history of Westeros because this is
your latest book it's and you know as I
said at the beginning it's a masterpiece
of popular history and you can tell how
steeped you are in the form because of
the the way you've constructed this book
tell us why you chose to do this pulling
together earlier writings I think on
something quite substantial on the
history of Westeros why put this
together now well you know as I was
writing the books I would I would have
people think about or refer to things
that happened in history occasionally
from time to time and it's actually in
the novels references to dead kings
references to legendary Knights and so
forth of the past
at a certain point my publishers said we
want to publish a concordance we want to
publish a world book because you've got
all this history in that and again I was
to the middle reigning novels I said
yeah well that's a great idea I'd love
it to test I wanted heavily Illustrated
I want lots of gorgeous fantasy on it
and I'd love LLL astrayed books I always
has since I was a kid reading you know
Robin Hood and King Arthur books
illustrated by people like Howard Pyle
and and C Wyeth gorgeous gorgeous books
I cut my teeth on those so I wanted my
books done the same way so and I said
and and you know I have I have little
bits of history in my head that I
haven't had an opportunity to put in the
books yet it put in the novels yet but
I'll include them too as sidebars so we
hired Elio Garcia and Linden Thompson
who are two of my
Buber fans they run the Westeros website
which is the oldest and the biggest of
the websites devoted to Westeros stones
book and they were supposed to organize
all the historical references that were
already in the novels assemble
everything and you know write a rough
account of it and then I would go in and
I would polish that rough account and
then I would put it in these side bars
material that had never appeared so we
were supposed to have 50,000 words of
prose and then the rest would be art or
on every page gorgeous art so by the
time Elio and Linda had assembled
everything we already had seventy
thousand words of prose and then I wrote
three hundred and fifty thousand words
of sidebars my publicist said wait wait
we can't we can't do this is this there
won't be art at every page we've already
spent the whole art budget there'll be
art every 20 pages so we ripped out all
my sidebars and you know we got the book
together it was published a few years
ago the world of Ice and Fire for a nice
book beautiful but but then I had all
these leftover sidebars that were kind
of a history of various Targaryen Kings
and I could have written more I was only
like halfway through writing the
sidebars when when I realized how long
they were so at a certain point when we
realized that Game of Thrones the TV
show was winding down but there might be
successful TV shows I said to my
publishers well we want to we've always
been talking about doing this history
book which I was calling the Grimm are
really on as a play on token should I
finish wins first or should I because
the groomer early on is almost complete
at least up to Aegon the Regency of
Aegon the third and it includes material
in it that is going to be the basis of
some of these successor shows so maybe
we should get out first before the shows
and they agreed so they said yeah that
finish that one and and then go back to
winds of winter so I sat down to finish
that when I polished all of the material
I'd written I expanded a few to sidebars
but then I had to write you know that
there was particularly King Joe Harris
the first Joe Harris the conciliator I'd
kind of skipped over him in the sidebars
because he was the old king he reigned
for 55 years and I just sort of written
55 years of peace and pus
prosperity and that was the big hole in
this book and I said well I can't just
have two sentences on your hair as he
ran for 55 years
55 years of peace and prosperity is
pretty dull though there must have been
something that happened during that and
I started inventing all the things that
happened during Joe Harris's rain all of
his children were men who were trouble
in many different ways and conspiracies
and you know the roughness when he first
took things and what I loved it and I
finished all that and I finally got the
whole book done - through the Regency of
Aegon the third and I'm very pleased
with it I it's it's different I know
many of you are getting a copy here as
while you were here it's it's not a
conventional novel it is imaginary
history written in the style I'd you've
probably read my real influence on this
was Thomas because stains for volume
history the Plantagenet switch any of
you have not read you know go out and
find a copy in the used book store it's
it's wonderfully written it's full of
great great stories most of which
academic historians have probably
disproved by now but they're still
terrific stories and and the Plantagenet
for a family that was equally
interesting as to the Targaryen they
lacked only dragons otherwise otherwise
they would be right up there
so that was my influence and I tried to
do that in this imaginary history book
it's Costin is the second best book ever
written about the Plantagenets actually
one more question here submitted from an
audience member aurelie percy i think is
the name the second volume of fire and
blood won't come out anytime soon so
very pessimistic about your output
maybe maybe with some justification but
could you could you give us an idea of
some elements that it will contain we go
up to the reign of Aegon the unlucky
here what at one of the highlights of
the putative next volume of this well I
mean that I act I this book on he goes
up to the Regency of Aegon and ends when
Aegon the third actually reaches
mandarin takes control so i have his
reign to cover which includes the death
of the last dragons
although Aegon the third is called the
dragon bane there are still three or
four dragons kicking around when he
takes the crown and there were none by
the time he's over so that one thing I
was going to cover why and what happens
there and some of the troubles and
rebellions of his reign and then
ultimately his children who are fairly
interesting I mean he has ultimately
five one of whom is there on the first a
young dragon who conquers Dorne and he's
a 14 year old Alexander the great kind
of hero king figure but he dies young
and then his his brother Bay Lord takes
over and Baylor is very religious very
he's a more of a st. Louis kind of
figure little extreme and his
religiosity and among other things he
imprisons his three sisters in luxurious
imprisonment and the red cape the maiden
volt but he doesn't like them like
walking around court because they tempt
him with you know they have breasts and
things underneath their clothes and he
finds that very disturbing to
contemplate so he hides them away so
I'll tell their stories and I'll tell
Baylor story and then after him well we
get a brief a brief reign of Viserys the
second and then the serious son Aegon
the fourth Aegon the unworthy takes over
and he's a very colorful figure himself
I obviously drew on Henry the eighth for
him you know Henry the Eighth had six
wives Aegon the unworthy had nine
mistresses and they're all existed my
head I know who they all were and what
happened to each of them and who was
where their head chopped off and who
you know had affairs and who did what so
there's a lot of cool material that and
then you get into the Blackfyre
rebellion which were five I've referred
to them frequently so I'll get all the
details on the Blackfyre rebellion z'
and ultimately we'll get up to the the
Mad King and Robert's rebellion and
that's where I'll draw to a close but
what am I going to write it well I got
to finish winds of winter first and then
probably a Duncan egg and then yeah I
don't know I don't know I need I need
more hours in the day and I need to be
20 years younger and all of that but I'm
tell you you could only write one word
at a time so that's what I'm doing